those are the innocent faces uh they
were supposed to be in a safe space at
their elementary school classroom in
yvaldi texas
until tragedy struck this is
entertainment tonight you know we're
here to bring you hollywood news usually
but there's just a collective heartbreak
that we're all experiencing right now
but none more so than the families who
woke up today dealing with unimaginable
loss
and despair
there is nothing that can ever be said
that can approach the immeasurable grief
of those families
my daughter's not there yet i'm trying
to find out where my baby's at who
wanted to take her life
oh we can open this she's just not a
number when i drop my kids off at school
this morning it doesn't cross your mind
that that could ever be the last goodbye
as the country grieves for these 19
innocent fourth graders and the two
teachers who selflessly sacrifice their
lives trying to save them
it's impossible to find words that
encompass the full magnitude of horror
that unfolded when an 18 year old gunman
invaded uvalde texas's robb elementary
school let me assure you the intruder is
deceased
the tragedy hits hard for father of
three and uvalde native matthew
mcconaughey his youngest child
livingston is around the same age as the
victims matthew posted quote to those
who dropped off their loved ones today
not knowing it was goodbye if prayers
can provide comfort we will keep them
coming we know how much you love texas
you ride for texas when any sort of
disaster comes a real crisis you gotta
try and stabilize first matthew attended
st phillips episcopal school which is
also where his mom taught kindergarten
the school is just four minutes down the
road from rob elementary have you ever
thought about ever leaving texas was
there ever a time i'd always have to
have roots here in 2016 e.t spent a day
in texas at the farm of matthew's older
brother rooster so talk to me about
growing up a mcconaughey well
it's been a
been a pretty good ride i guess in 2020
matthew his mother kay and rooster
returned to uvalde for the town's
centennial celebration the valley was
the most perfect place to raise children
seven asked this um
you know did you learn to to dream in
uvalde and the answer is no i actually
didn't learn to dream i learned a deal
and hollywood's been quick to react to
the tragedy last night cbs pulled the
fbi season 4 finale the story line
revolved around a school shooting rose
byrne's red carpet for the season 2
premiere of physical was canceled and
elsewhere stars were speaking out just
rage
and heartbreak like i have a little
three-year-old and the thought of like
being one of the families getting that
call
it's just unimaginable i am from texas
no one should rest easy tonight taylor
swift tim mcgraw gabrielle union and
more were vocal on social media chris
evans tweeting simply expletive enough
texas native selena gomez posting
changed the laws to prevent these
shootings the issue also took center
stage today on the view if your thoughts
and prayers were really with everybody
you'd have done something by now
stop gaslighting us there is no reason
why an 18 year old should have access to
weapons of war that can kill children in
a matter of seconds tennis star andy
murray who survived a school shooting at
age eight called the texas tragedy
madness and there was more anger at an
nba pregame press conference when are we
gonna do something
i'm tired of the moments of silence
enough golden state warriors head coach
steve kerr lost his father as a teen in
1984. malcolm kerr a university
president was gunned down on his campus
and last night steve stormed off
criticizing lawmakers for inaction on
gun control they won't vote on it
because they want to hold on to their
own power
it's pathetic i've had enough
you have voted against two gun gun
reform measures we need change
congressman we need change
and on cbs mornings congressman tony
gonzalez who represents uvalde got tense
with gail king i want my children to be
safe everywhere they go guess what just
like every other father and mother in
america congress and others should be
having these conversations not the
division congress there's too much
division in this country i have not
slept yet because i am
enraged i am a parent of children
that had these active shooter drills and
before you tell me to stay in my lane
this is my lane this is my lane
amen kelly it is all of our lane all of
us yeah and i want to go back to andy
murray the former world number one in
tennis for a second he survived that
school shooting in the uk in 1996. well
parliament was quick to enact gun
control legislation and there hasn't
been a school shooting since
my heart is just
yeah it's broken
[Music]
you